and America has a stunning breathtaking
history of diplomatic failure when it
comes to curbing North Korea's nuclear
and missile programs since 1985 US
administrations have tried embargoes
have done sanctions threats treaties and
appeasement but no combination of sticks
and carrots has ever worked so why could
it be different this time let's go back
to our panel here in Washington to
discuss that Mike Pillsbury Harry cos
Yanis dr. walid Farris Mike you you want
to address a point as a former
government official how things really go
behind closed doors and how we talk
about them as members of the media we
want to be very careful I want you to
touch on that but I want you to touch on
the one-and-done point that Trump made
he basically said you got one shot at
this young man and this is it is that
just bluster or is that really do you
think the way it feels here I think it's
in the context of the military exercises
the military threats last year the
extreme sanctions perhaps some other
things that have been going on we don't
know about yet there's a kind of
intimidation of Chairman Kim he's only
34 years old he's now very poised he's
calling me sort of touching president
Trump's arm the way President Trump
touched his arm so on the surface there
is this kind of mild camaraderie but as
a government official I look at this in
terms of the media outside Chris Wallace
and the others they have no idea what is
going on in that room for all we know
none of us do there's close to a walkout
and back to the tables and even military
threats or it's the opposite that
they've got a schedule for this
mentleman they've got some specific
things that they've been talking about
first you stopped the plutonium
reprocessing then you do this with the
underground uranium enrichment facility
in the case of both Nixon and Mao and
later on with Gorbachev and at Reykjavik
the documents were kept secret for 30
years scholars only found out ah this is
what the deal was
maybe full after all all these are
people it's about a premature commentary
going on
a limb some of these journalists who
think they know what's going on they
really don't so I have a hunch that
we're going to learn more at the press
conference but only as we begin to see
when will be the first dismantlement or
the first then there have been two small
steps already the the blowing up of the
tunnels with the press nearby it wasn't
a hoax it may not have been much maybe
the mountain was tired it was already
collapse before everything is this
strange story recently about the missile
testing facility being disabled so it's
not right to say nothing's been done by
North Korea at this point that